claus strunz noch einmal bei uns und wir
konnten jetzt beide noch mal ganz kurz
zu hören natürlich für markus söder
jetzt einfacher was dazu zu sagen als
für armin laschet auch er sagt er hat
das jetzt erst mal zur kenntnis genommen
wir haben beide gerade auf dich gewirkt
und vor allem wie geht's jetzt wohl in
den nächsten tagen weiter was muss armin
laschet nach diesen tag machen peter
tiede meinte mund abputzen aufstehen wie
einfach ist das beide haben gewirkt wie
seriöse männer wie seriöse politiker wie
statthafte zu landen
sicherlich geht der tag heute an markus
söder
das ist ganz unbestreitbar so wir wollen
aber nicht vergessen dass der tag zuvor
an armin laschet ging also das bedeutet
sie sind schon immer noch kopf an kopf
vielleicht zwei gedanken noch der eine
ist was die menschen um die sie am ende
geht
da draußen bürger jetzt wahrnehmen ist
ja ein geschachere um macht keiner zieht
zurück und die fakten spielen keine
rolle
also es gibt einen kandidaten der die
besseren umfragen der ist offensichtlich
in den winter fraktionen beliebter und
den würden die menschen in deutschland
eher wählen als den anderen
die parteiführung die gremien die oberen
die bosse die granden entscheiden sich
aber für den der nicht die besseren
umfrageergebnisse hat dem die fraktion
nicht im meinungsbild das vertrauen
ausgesprochen hat und den auch nicht
nachstand jetzt die die meisten
deutschen wählen würden
das kriegt man einem menschen der
sowieso glaubt politik ist irgendwie was
komisches was in berlin komische leute
entscheiden nicht erklärt dass es gegen
jede vorstellungskraft jetzt
funktioniert politik aber so wir sehen
das ja jeden tag ich glaube das ist ein
weiterer beweis ist er sich dass
offensichtlich geändert und das bedeutet
und da bin ich dann doch auch bei paul
das ist sehr offen ist ja mehr noch
eigentlich nur armin laschet kann jetzt
noch armin laschet verhindern weil armin
laschet hat das vorschlagsrecht wenn
armin laschet nicht zurückzieht wir
machen mal jetzt den eskalation
die beiden treffen sich am donnerstag
tag abend sitzen beieinander oder nein
beim frühstück am freitag um sozusagen
geschichte in der geschichte den
richtigen platz zu finden für dieses
treffen und lasse sagt markus ich habe
jetzt über alles nachgedacht ich mache
es ich werde mich vorschlagen
dann wird es so kommen und dann muss das
ist der moment um egos oder einschränken
muss und sagen muss gut dann bin ich in
deinem team dabei also der stärkere in
diesen mann zu mann gespräch ist armin
laschet weil er ist entscheidet aber die
frage ist klaus bp total beide sich
genauso nur die frage ist was passiert
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt noch und was
spielt da eine rolle und da glaube ich
ist die große frage ob einer dieser
cdu-granden die vorher noch scheinbar
hinter armin laschet standen oder sich
sogar öffentlich geäußert haben für
armin laschet einer von den umfeld also
ob markus söder am ende sagen kann das
was ist am montag gab nämlich eine
einhellige unterstützung im cdu
präsidium und bundesvorstand das gibt's
nicht mehr armin also ich glaube das
wäre die einzige echte gefahr die
sozusagen das ganze zum einsturz bringen
derjenige ich finde zu formulieren dass
er umfeld ist aus der perspektive der
cdu heraus richtig man könnte aber auch
sagen
einer hört auf die fraktion
wenigstens einer macht sich ehrlich und
sagt das sind doch unsere leute die mit
den menschen da draußen in kontakt sind
haben uns offensichtlich ein bisschen
vertan mit unserer mit unserer
meinungsbild im präsidium und den
vorstand
ich schränke und dann würde es
tatsächlich reichen wenn das nur markus
söder und armin laschet wüssten
derjenige müsste sich noch nicht mal
öffentlich erklären
es müsste nur unter den dreien klar sein
in dem gespräch man nicht gegen mann
sondern mit man müsste sie da sagen aber
armin du weißt doch der ich will jetzt
kein rein ich will jetzt nicht einreißen
ja aber der hat sich neu positioniert